- Hello Believe Nation.
I want your thoughts on what topics
you want me to answer for you.
♫9
♫ 8
♫ 7
(electronic music)
- So I've been getting a lot
of emails, a lot of tweets,
a lot of YouTube comments, a
lot of messages from people
who have questions for their
business from your guys
who want help in growing your company.
You have some specific questions for me,
and it's been impossible for
me to get back to everybody,
and so what I wanted to
do was use this channel,
use this series, as an
opportunity to answer questions
from you guys and either
make a 7 ways video
to help answer your question
or maybe something else
but I want to use this
video right here, this video
and the comments below for you guys
to write down the questions and the topics
that you want me to cover and
so what we'll do is every week
as I go through this, look at which
are the most popular questions,
which one will help the most of you
and that's what we'll make a video on.
So if you have a question for me
that you'd like me to cover,
leave it down on the comments below.
If you want to vote on the ones
that you want to see me
answer and make a video on,
then give it a thumbs up to
the people who commented below
and every week I'm going to go
through and look at the top ones
and those are the ones we
are going to make videos on.
So it's a test, it's an experiment.
I'd love to know what you guys think,
looking forward to seeing
your comments down below.
Much love, continue to
believe, and I'll see you soon.